Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Earlier, we talked about an amazing technique
where the inputs were a source video of ourselves,
and a target actor.
And the output was a
reenactment, in other words, a video of this
target actor with our facial gestures.
This requires only a few minutes of video
from the target which is usually already available
on the internet.
Essentially, we can impersonate other people,
at least for one video.
A key part of this new technique is that it
extracts additional data such as pose and
eye positions both from the source and target
videos, and uses this data for the reconstruction.
As opposed to this original Face2face technique
from 2 years ago, which was already mind-blowing,
you see here that this results in a new learning-based
method that supports the reenactment of eyebrows
and blinking, changing the background, plus
head and gaze positioning as well.
So far, this would still be similar to a non
learning-based technique we've seen a few
episodes ago.
And now, hold on to your papers, because this
algorithm enables us to not only impersonate,
but also control the characters in the output
video.
The results are truly mesmerizing, I almost
fell out of the chair when I've first seen
them.
And what's more, we can create really rich
reenactments by editing the expressions, pose,
and blinking separately by hand.
What also needs to be emphasized here is that
we see and talk to other human beings all
the time, so we have a remarkably keen eye
for these kinds of gestures.
If something is off by just a few millimeters
or is not animated in a way that is close
to perfect, the illusion immediately falls
apart.
And the magical thing about these techniques
is that every single iteration we get something
that is way beyond the capabilities of the
previous methods.
And they come in quick succession.
There are plenty of more comparisons in the
paper as well, so make sure to have a look.
It also contains a great idea that opens up
the possibility of creating quantitative evaluations
against ground truth footage.
Turns out that we can have such a thing as
ground truth footage.
I wonder when we will see the first movie
with this kind of reenactment of an actor
who passed away.
Do you have some other cool applications in
mind?
Let me know in the comments section.
And, if you enjoyed this episode, make sure
to pick up some cool perks on our Patreon
page where you can manage your paper addiction
by getting early access to these episodes
and more.
We also support cryptocurrencies, the addresses
are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!